There seemed to be an
implication in your-- first
of all, great talks.
Really, these are fantastic
that we're having these at Yale.
So I'm saying this with love.
So the first question
is I just seem
to get the implication
that you were suggesting
that exploratory research
shouldn't be registered
and that people
should be- and what
I believe is that
if you're going
to do exploratory
research, that's great.
And we should be publishing
exploratory research.
We should be prioritizing
We should register that we're
doing exploratory research.
And we should give a
methods history of that.
I think that sometimes
people don't take a moment
to say what exactly,
what question
am I actually trying
to answer here.
I'm just reflecting
on my own group.
The time that they
spent registering
should be the time that they
spent organizing their ideas
about what exactly am I doing.
And the registration
process shouldn't
be burdensome beyond that.
But it should
enable them a pause
to say it's not just
I've got all this data,
and let me just run around.
But let me take a moment to
see if I'm really a scientist.
Then I should be able to at
least define what I'm doing.
Even if that definition is
discovery and exploration.
But what question
am I answering.
I just wanted your
response to that.
Because it just seemed
as almost you said,
well, this will slow them
down and it discourages them.
And then, you said then if
they get negative results,
it's all for naught.
When actually, the negative
results should be informative.
And so it's about, if you flip
the question, hey, I did this,
I didn't find anything.
The next person
can build on that.
What are your
thoughts about that?
Great, so I'll start
with the last point,
which is-- so there's a model.
Platt had a science
piece, I think 1964,
entitled strong inference.
And his argument was
scientific fields advance
most quickly when they pose
sort of questions where
an experiment can answer
it, and either answer
will be informative.
So that is a model of science.
And we would love to have-- and
we should encourage researchers
to find those questions where
any answer, whether it's null,
or whatever the outcome
of the experiment,
it informs the community.
That being said, the
reality is it's often--
that's not the only model
of scientific inference.
Another model is one where--
another one, another model
is one where you're
sort of taking a chance.
So you might have a hypothesis.
So I'm being speaking
to this last point,
and then I'll come
back to this one.
You have a hypothesis
that I don't believe.
Maybe 1% of the community
believes your hypothesis.
I wouldn't put money
on it, but you're
willing to put
some time into it.
And if you end up finding
evidence supporting of it,
then that's a huge
contribution to science,
because you've
moved our beliefs.
Our prior was
strongly against it.
You provided evidence.
So I think a lot of
work has that character.
And for that reason, if you find
evidence consistent with what
the community
already believed, it
will be harder to publish
and advance you career.
It should absolutely
be published somewhere.
It should enter the record.
Pre-prints.
Yeah, but the poor grad student
who spent three months on that
would have been better served
if they thought of their work
more in an exploratory
mode, because they were not
in a position to
theorize ex ante.
So to clarify, I think
of a confirmatory
versus exploratory
more as a continuum.
There's an edge where you have
pure confirmatory research,
where you have a
pre-analysis plan.
The code is all written up.
And then we really know that
the p-value has the properties,
or the other tests have the
properties that statistic
says they should have.
However, we're rarely even there
with thorough preregistration.
There's often
degrees of freedom,
researcher degrees of
freedom, different ways
you can analyze your data.
And the more degrees
of freedom you have,
the more possibility
there are that a p-value
will be deflated, because
of selection for it,
sort of interesting results.
So I think my recommendation
is, yes, scholars
should do exploratory analysis.
They could do
exploratory experiments.
Rather than feeling obliged to
make their one experiment thee
experiment.
But there's real value
to preregistering all
throughout the
continuum, just, I
think, for what you're saying,
to make it transparent,
what the motive inference
was that you were adopting.
I agree, and I think
it's just declaring
this is what I'm doing.
And then I want to give
that person value for it
if it was worthwhile.
Just one quick question on--
great talk about the policies,
but what do we do when
the policies really
aren't being enforced?
So I mean, even in the
Obama administration,
you FOIA information
out of the FDA,
you're going to be
waiting until you're old.
You know, they can talk
about open government,
but it's not really, when
it's coming to FOiA requests.
And on some hands,
we've made progress.
On other hands,
we really haven't.
And I think it's not consistent.
And with regard
to, take example,
what's going to go on PMI.
The data holders, the
health care institutions,
are failing to comply with
federal regulations in the High
Tech Act of 2009.
And the government fails
to push it forward.
So I think it's a
question how we are also
advocating for the government,
not just to make the policies,
but to enforce
them, so that people
can respect them and ensure
that they're being followed.
I don't know-- to the extent
this is a question about what
can be done, let me say two
things here, both of which
are unsatisfactory.
The first is that one of
the unsatisfactory things
is that there were two
parallel processes that emerged
in the Obama administration.
One was an open
government and open data
process run by one set of
actors, who were primarily
technical people.
And the other was a track,
that was essentially
the FOIA track, which is
essentially run by the lawyers.
And that's one of
the challenges.
So I would frequently
talk to stakeholders
who would say I want
data set x, and I
would say don't call the
FOIA people, call the open,
call the CIO, call the CTO,
call the policy-- if you
call the other side of the
shop, you might be very lucky.
So that's not fully an answer.
The truth is that you
got to work the system.
And what's happening-- so I
just literally submitted a grant
proposal to say,
to a funder, to say
we've been doing all
this great training
with all these chief innovation
officers, chief technologists.
We have chief data
scientists in places.
They get it.
But we're not
teaching the lawyers.
And by the way, it's
one of the reasons
I'm back here at my Alma mater.
My home base is-- I'm at the
engineering school at NYU.
But you know, it's
the lawyers who
actually need to be
brought along for the ride
because they view
themselves rightly
as the safeguards
of due process,
as the safeguarders
of the public trust.
But you know what?
The world is moving on in terms
of understanding openness.
By the way, we just did
a huge report on openness
in the grant making
process, trying
to push grant innovations.
Lots of people on board, but
the lawyers are like what?
So, we're catching
them by surprise
by not training those
people and bringing them
in as part of the conversation.
So the FDA is a very,
as you know, mixed bag.
I've been working with the FDA
for a very, very long time.
We made a lot of
progress on opening up
some data when Josh was there.
He and I worked on creating a
transparency initiative FDA.
We got some data out.
Sadly he left, and I left.
Right now, we're
working on another piece
of things, which
I'll just mention,
to put it on your radar screen.
One of the big problems we've
seen at a lot of these places
is data readiness.
So, again, it's
like people don't
get what to do with the
data internal to government.
So yeah, you have a
dengue forecasting project
at HHS, which is very
sophisticated in terms
of let's use predictive
analytics to spot dengue.
But in most-- I'm
working with the NHS
in England, a huge organization
opening up a lot of its data.
You know how many
people they have,
who have the title of
analyst, or anything
to do with data in their title?
150 people in an organization
that has millions in it.
Now there's a lot of talent
that's hiding in plain sight,
but you don't have people
in decision making roles
who even begin to understand
what the value is of data
or how to use it.
It's a very mixed bag.
The Commerce Department
here has 30 data scientists
sitting at the top to the
right of the secretary.
Other agencies, they
don't know from data.
So it's partly,
you know, the FDA
has its own very significant
challenges in terms
of the outside lobbying on it.
But in part , there's a lot
of work to be done culturally
in terms of bringing
the no machines, aka,
the lawyers and the procurement
people along for the ride,
finding the people
who are data savvy,
and putting them in key roles.
So I think that talent
is a big piece of it.
So I think there's
work that can be done.
I would not, however,
put a lot of money
on the next administration.
But we may be
pleasantly surprised
if we keep telling them
that open data creates jobs
that we can keep in the
United States, who knows.
Maybe we can have
some successes.
But I put my money on Mexico
right now, and Canada.
For open date-- I
don't mean-- and moving
there, but on open data,
they're both better
than we are at the moment.
Well, thank you for two
very good presentations.
My question is to Beth.
In your experience
in government,
what is the current
status, or did you ever
have any conversations about
making tax return data open?
What's the status there?
And second, when
data are gathered
through social
economic processes,
as opposed to mechanical
automatic processes,
you concern yourself
with a trade off,
between the openness of data
and the quality of data,
deterioration of the data.
Oh, tax data, I have a great
success story to report
that will surprise you I hope.
So, not the story you're
actually asking me about,
but nonprofit tax return data.
I know you want
individual taxes.
Let me say on the
individual tax return side,
I think the question
has to do with providing
me back my own data.
So it's the story of what
Deb Estrin at Cornell Tech
calls small data.
If you're Nigel
Shadbolt at Southampton,
you call it my data.
So processes of
creating open data.
My data that you give back to
me, whether it's my health care
record or my tax return, I would
say there, the IRS is at zero.
Where we have made progress
is on the nonprofit tax return
front.
So by law, nonprofits
like Yale, file their 990s
with the government, at the
federal level and the state
level.
And those tax returns by law
are supposed to be made open.
Now, the openness that they
were providing previously
was if you electronically
filed your returns,
the IRS would print them out,
scam them back in and then
put that image file on a DVD.
And once a year for $20,000
you could buy that DVD.
I'm going to fast forward a
lot of pain personally suffered
to say that now you can download
that data from the Amazon
Cloud, hooray.
The other part of that story,
which is unfolding as we speak
is that 12 states
are working together
to pilot a one-stop
filing system.
So instead of having to go to
every single state in which you
operate, you can
go to one website,
click, click, click, click,
click, file your returns,
and then that data will be
made automatically open.
We, by the way, are
making companies
like Guidestar a little unhappy.
And people whose business
model, who are like the Apple
iTunes of tax returns.
But they're adjusting,
and they'll live,
and they'll provide
value added services that
are not about selling the data.
So there is a very
happy news there.
For the story about how we
actually track tax data,
I would point you to the
work of a scholar named
Julia Lane, an economist who's
now moved to NYU from Chicago
this year, who's
done a lot of work
on creating, getting access,
combining grants data, tax
data, census data, so
that we can actually
track the value of government
investment in science.
So if the government gives
$1 to Yale for science,
we should be able to
know, and tax return data
is essential to that,
what the economic,
the downstream
economic impact is
of those investments in science.
So that's again a
story about data.
You know, the "Fifty
Shades of Gray,"
it's not about open data,
but about responsible access
to data that we're
making some progress
on by virtue of having put some
innovation rules into the IRS.
And the last part of this story
is commitments that are abroad,
primarily around opening up
corporate beneficial ownership
data, which is partly coming
from tax returns, which
is knowing who's the
real owner of a company.
The UK has made
progress on this front
and other countries are
trying to move forward
and actually trying to tell us
who owns the companies that we
do business with, which is
a huge other consideration.
My question is about 1040.
Yeah, no, no.
[INAUDIBLE] we have used
for about last 20 years.
No, no progress, zero.
Nothing to say.
I mean, even access,
I mean, the IRS
has a statistical
division that does
pull samples of the tax data in
order to do statistical work.
I would say there's
been no investment
or progress on this front.
I mean, there's a desire just to
simplify the forms that we fill
out and to create simpler
tax filing systems,
or even to create a default like
they have in other countries,
where the government
automatically
files my tax return
and then I correct it,
but we've made no
progress on this.
Does anybody else have
better news to report?
I thought I had happy-- I had
happy news on some fronts.
I will be briefer in my
response, my apologies.
Hi, how are you?
Thank you very
much for the chat.
I'm [INAUDIBLE], I'm a graduate
student of school of forestry.
I wanted to ask
you about what are
your thoughts about
the openness of data
from government, but not
only about the raw data
they use for policy making,
but also about the methods they
use, and how can organizations
like the open data,
open government
partnership can actually
encourage these in not only
that the United States,
but in other governments that
might be also producing data,
but at the same time, getting
to know how they actually use
them to provide public policy.
So there are, in terms of
things like-- so there effort
in sectors.
So things like the open
contracting partnership
are working to help standardize,
to help governments know
how to publish their data,
their contracting data
and how to
standardize that data.
There are working groups
that are more technical that
are focused on things like data
quality and data standards,
including there's a
group that was stood up
called the Open Data
Institute out of the UK,
which is co-chaired by
Nigel Shadbolt and Sir Tim
Berners-Lee.
And they do a bit of this work,
trying to help governments
with their data practices.
I think partly what's
happening is a move spurred
by hiring a White House level
chief data scientist trying
to create a community of data
scientists in government.
So commerce, for example
has been in the lead
and trying to
provide then guidance
and training for
other agencies, as you
see people start to replicate
creating data savvy roles
within the agencies.
But there really is a
tremendous shortage.
We see a tremendous shortage
in the private sector of people
with data science training.
Everybody's clamoring
for data scientists.
So thank goodness Yale
has this long list
of things that's
getting started.
But to the extent to
which we can encourage
some of those people
to go do work,
or at least a tour of duty
with the public sector,
I think it's
incredibly important.
Because, you know, right now
we have to rely on the fact
that we're putting
out data that often
is of extremely low quality,
that's poorly collected,
and we also don't
know-- forgetting
about the fact that
the methods that we
use to analyze that data are
still very nascent I was,
last week, at the
launch at Imperial
College of the new center for
the mathematics of precision
health care, which is
simply about developing
the mathematical
models and methods that
can be then applied to
looking at health care data.
You know, it's a group
of mathematicians
working with clinicians.
And so I think we have
a very long way to go.
We particularly have a long way
to go because of the talent gap
that we see in government.
So pockets of work, and are
happy to share more by email,
but one of the big-- let me just
say that the big challenge is
when it continues
to be work that's
done by-- if it's
done by diplomats,
we don't get very far.
And then one layer down
to the policy makers,
but we need those policy makers
to be people who actually have
some data science training.
So next month we're
going to launch
a course, an online free loop
called data analytical thinking
aimed at mid-level government
officials who don't know
anything about data,
precisely to discuss,
to help, bring people
along for the ride.
I'd like to thank
Professors Novak and.
Dafoe.
[APPLAUSE]